This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Though the cups at Starbucks have been read since the day after Halloween, Thanksgiving marks the start of the holiday season for most people. That means taking the time to reflect on everything we're grateful for, being generous, spending time with the people we love. So you can say to yourself, I can't get into an argument with Uncle Joe, but that might not work nearly as well as saying, you know, I don't get into stupid political fights
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维达塔姆。尽管星巴克的纸杯从万圣节过后就开始有节日气氛了，但对大多数人来说，感恩节才是假期季的开始。这意味着我们要花时间反思我们所感激的一切、慷慨待人、与所爱之人共度时光。所以你可以对自己说：“我不能跟乔叔叔吵架，”但这可能远远不如说：“你知道的，我不会和那些不知道自己在胡说八道的人进行愚蠢的政治争论。”
with people who don't know what they're talking about. We all know that the whole spending time with the people we love part can be a little challenging. When you refuse to apologize, it actually makes you feel more empowered. On this week's episode, we'll talk about some themes that often come up in disagreements around the dinner table and we'll give you some strategies to help keep the peace.
我们都知道，与我们所爱的人共度时光这一部分可能会有点挑战。当你拒绝道歉时，这实际上会让你感到更有力量。在本周的节目中，我们将讨论餐桌争论中经常出现的几个主题，并为你提供一些有助于维持和平的策略。
This holiday week, we're going to bring you two short conversations I had with Steve Inskeep. He's a host of NPR's Morning Edition. If you haven't heard me on the air, I often talk with Steve about new social science research on the radio. After that, we're going to have a brand new edition of Stopwatch Science with Daniel Pink. Our theme throughout this episode is how social science can help you have a happy Thanksgiving. So let's do it right, and Wendy, why don't you say grace? You still love to say grace,
在这个感恩节周，我们将为你带来我与史蒂夫·因斯基普进行的两次简短对话。他是美国国家公共电台（NPR）《早间新闻》的主持人。如果你没听过我的广播，我经常在广播里和史蒂夫探讨新的社会科学研究。之后，我们将带来丹尼尔·平克带来的全新一期“秒表科学”。我们本期节目的主题是社会科学如何能帮你过一个快乐的感恩节。所以我们要好好表现，温蒂，你为什么不来谢饭呢？你还是很喜欢谢饭，
remember? Dear Lord, thank you for this Thanksgiving holiday, and for all the material possessions that we have and enjoy. And for letting us white and for all the material possessions that we have and enjoy. And for letting us white people kill all the Indians and steal their tribal lands and stuff ourselves like pigs, even though we're children of Asia, we may bond. The Thanksgiving dinner table can be a place where tensions arise as in that clip from the 1997 movie, The Ice Storm. And very often, those fights tend to be about politics.
对吧？亲爱的主啊，感谢你赐予我们这个感恩节假期，以及我们拥有和享受的所有物质财富。还有让我们白人……以及我们拥有和享受的所有物质财富。还有让我们白人杀光印第安人，窃取他们的部落土地，像猪一样把自己塞得满满的，尽管我们是亚洲人的后代，我们也可以建立纽带。感恩节餐桌可能会成为一个关系紧张的地方，正如1997年电影《冰风暴》中的那个片段一样。很多时候，这些争吵往往是关于政治的。
Stevens keep asked me why it's so difficult to find common ground in these conversations. Okay, so what's the new research? The research looks at seemingly intractable conflicts, such as the conflicts between Democrats and Republicans, and it shows that, besides disagreements about the issues, there's an underlying psychological process that makes a search for common ground really difficult. The research comes from Leanne Young at Boston College, and along with Adam Wates and Jeremy Ginges, she asked Democrats and Republicans about the emotions that motivate them and the
史蒂夫·因斯基普问我，为什么在这些对话中很难找到共同点。好吧，那么有什么新研究呢？这项研究着眼于看似棘手的冲突，例如民主党和共和党之间的冲突，它表明，除了对议题的分歧之外，还有一个潜在的心理过程，使得寻找共同点变得非常困难。这项研究来自波士顿学院的莉安·杨，她与亚当·沃茨和杰里米·金杰斯一起，询问了民主党人和共和党人关于激励他们的情绪以及
emotions that motivate their opponents. Both sides said that they were motivated by positive emotions such as love or loyalty to their fellow Republicans or their fellow Democrats, but that that they were motivated by positive emotions, such as love or loyalty to their fellow Republicans or their fellow Democrats, but that their opponents were motivated primarily by hate and animosity. Now this was true of both Republicans and Democrats. Here's young talking about the Democratic volunteers. Democrats were much more likely to say that they are motivated by love compared to hate.
激励他们对手的情绪。双方都表示，他们受到积极情绪的激励，比如对同为共和党人或同为民主党人的爱或忠诚，但……他们受到积极情绪的激励，比如对同为共和党人或同为民主党人的爱或忠诚，但他们的对手主要是受恨意和敌意的驱动。共和党人和民主党人都是如此。这里杨在谈论民主党志愿者。民主党人更有可能说，与恨相比，他们受爱的驱使。
We then went and asked them how much is the Republican Party motivated by love and hate. And there we found that Democrats were likely to say that Republicans were motivated by their hate of Democrats rather than their love of Republicans. Okay, so the research says that I'm thinking the worst of the other guy, or more properly, I think that you're thinking the worst of the other guy or more properly, I think that you're thinking the worst
然后我们去问他们，共和党受爱和恨的驱动有多大。我们在那里发现，民主党人更有可能说，共和党人受对民主党的恨的驱动，而不是受对共和党的爱的驱动。好吧，所以研究表明，我在把对方往最坏处想，或者更准确地说，我认为你在把对方往最坏处想，或者更准确地说，我认为你在把最坏的一面
of me. I think you hate me and that colors my perceptions of you. That's precisely right, Steve. The point that young and her colleagues are making is that if we believe that our opponents hate us, it's really hard to imagine common ground. So this might be one reason conflicts end up being intractable, not just in politics, but in arguments over the Thanksgiving table. When we feel an aunt or an uncle or a grandparent is out to get us, we do everything we can to defend ourselves against this hate that's coming across the table. What we don't
加诸于我。我认为你恨我，这抹黑了我对你的看法。完全正确，史蒂夫。杨和她的同事们提出的观点是，如果我们相信我们的对手恨我们，就很难想象共同点。所以这可能是冲突最终难以解决的原因之一，不仅在政治上，在感恩节餐桌上的争论中也是如此。当我们觉得某个阿姨、叔叔或祖父母要找我们麻烦时，我们会竭尽全力保护自己，抵御桌对面传来的这种恨意。我们没有
often realize is the person sitting across the table is trying to defend themselves from what they think is our hate for them. So young and her colleagues think that if we try to see the other side as also being driven by positive emotions such as loyalty or love rather than animosity, the arguments don't disappear, but it takes us to think out of the arguments. You know, we have a colleague here at work who talks about assuming the best intentions of the other person. I suppose that's the insight here is to assume the best of intentions of the partisan jerk across the table for me. That's exactly right, Steve. People live very different lives and they're coming together for Thanksgiving meals so it's not surprising. They're going to bring their loyalties to their own
经常意识到的是，坐在桌子对面的人正在试图保护自己，抵御他们认为我们对他们的恨。所以杨和她的同事认为，如果我们试图把对方也看作是由忠诚或爱等积极情绪驱动，而不是由敌意驱动，争论并不会消失，但这会让我们跳出争论。你知道，我们在工作中有个同事会谈到假设对方有最好的意图。我想这里的真知灼见就是假设我对面那个持党派偏见的混蛋怀有最好的意图。完全正确，史蒂夫。人们过着截然不同的生活，他们聚在一起吃感恩节大餐，所以这并不奇怪。他们会把对自己所属群体的忠诚带到共享的晚餐中。
groups to the shared dinner. Young told me she hopes to apply the lesson of her study to her own Thanksgiving if an argument happens to break out. Here she is. In the case of a fiery Thanksgiving debate it's good to give the benefit of the doubt that this person isn't arguing with me because they hate me, but I would tell myself, hey, you know, they want me to understand their point of you because they think it's right, and this grandparent is motivated by their love of me. But wait a minute here, suppose I try so hard to be big about this and to be open-minded and the other person is just a jerk, or I'm afraid the other person is hard to be big about this and to be open-minded and the other person is just a jerk or I'm afraid the other person is going to be a jerk. What would it take to get the other person to open their minds? Well that's a good question Steve. A young
杨告诉我，她希望将她研究的教训应用到她自己的感恩节中，如果争论爆发的话。她在这里说。在发生激烈的感恩节辩论时，最好给予对方充分的信任，认为这个人不是因为恨我才跟我争论，而是我会告诉自己，嘿，你知道的，他们希望我理解他们的观点，因为他们认为这是对的，这位祖父母是出于对我的爱才这样做的。但等一下，假设我非常努力地想表现得大度、思想开放，而对方却是个混蛋，或者我担心对方很难表现得大度、思想开放，而对方只是个混蛋，或者我担心对方会变成个混蛋。要怎样才能让对方敞开心扉呢？嗯，这是个好问题，史蒂夫。杨的
study actually might point to the solution because she and her colleagues wanted to see if they could do anything to get people to accurately perceive their opponent's point of view. Now since this is America they decided to to try the old fashion approach. They promised volunteers a financial incentive. Just pay them. Exactly. They found that when you tell Democrats and Republicans that they stand to earn about $10 if they can accurately describe what's happening in their political opponents' minds, both sides now say the views of their opponents are probably shaped by positive emotions such
研究实际上可能指出了解决方案，因为她和她的同事想看看他们是否能做些什么来让人们准确地感知对手的观点。既然这里是美国，他们决定尝试老式的做法。他们承诺向志愿者提供经济奖励。只是付钱给他们。完全正确。他们发现，当你告诉民主党人和共和党人，如果他们能准确描述他们的政治对手心里在想什么，他们就能赚到大约10美元时，双方现在都表示，他们对手的观点可能是由积极情绪塑造的，比如
as loyalty and love rather than hate. I asked Young whether the same technique might work at Thanksgiving dinner tables. Now I have to say she was very skeptical that this could work, but I say that we should run an experiment, slip a $10 bill under people's plates, and as they sit down, see if that gives us a happy Thanksgiving. Sean Kerr, there's a little something for you underneath your paper there. You know Steve, I always thought so highly of you. So hopefully your Thanksgiving dinner will be argument free.
忠诚和爱，而不是恨。我问杨，同样的技巧是否也适用于感恩节餐桌。现在我必须说，她对这是否行得通持高度怀疑态度，但我说我们应该做一个实验，把一张10美元的钞票塞在人们的盘子底下，当他们坐下时，看看这能否给我们带来一个快乐的感恩节。肖恩卡，你的纸底下有点小东西。你知道史蒂夫，我一直对你评价很高。所以希望你的感恩节晚餐不会有争吵。
But just in case it's not, our next story is about apologizing. In the 1973 movie, a Charlie Brown Thanksgiving, Peppermint Patty picks a fight at the dinner table. What kind of a Thanksgiving dinner is this? Where's the turkey chuck? Don't you know anything about Thanksgiving dinners? Where's the mashed potatoes? Where's the cranberry sauce? Where's the pumpkin pie?
但以防万一真的吵起来了，我们的下一个故事是关于道歉的。在1973年的电影《查理布朗的感恩节》中，薄荷帕蒂在餐桌上挑起了一场争端。这算什么感恩节晚餐？火鸡呢，查克？你难道对感恩节晚餐一无所知吗？土豆泥呢？越橘酱呢？南瓜派呢？
Sometimes we know we've done something wrong, but it's still really hard to say we're sorry. Do you think I heard old Chuck's feelings? I bet I heard his feelings, huh? know we've done something wrong, but it sounded. Marcy, you can do it. You go see him and tell him that I really like him and that the dinner is okay with me. Well, I don't know. I think maybe you should go to Chuck and tell him yourself. I talk to Steve about why I love you really can mean never having to say your sorry,
有时候我们知道自己做错了事，但要说声对不起依然很难。你觉得我伤了老查克的感情吗？我敢打赌我伤了他的感情，对吧？知道我们做错了事，但听起来确实如此。玛西，你能行的。你去找他，告诉他我真的很喜欢他，而且这晚餐对我来说也挺好。嗯，我不知道。我想也许你应该自己去找查克告诉他。我跟史蒂夫聊了聊为什么我爱你可以真正意味着永远不必说对不起，
or at least never wanting to. Okay, if you've ever looked after a group of children, chances are you've tried to break up a squabble using the following words. Come on now, just say your sorry. If your advice was met with stony, faced resistance, you will want to listen to this. Shankar, not sorry to have you here. So what do you mean, not apologizing? What is this about? Apologies present us with a puzzle. And the puzzle kids find it hard to do adults find it hard to do It's even hard when it's completely rational. So in the criminal justice system for example You have situations where someone has been found guilty and they're awaiting sentencing and the only thing that could reduce the
或者至少永远不想说。好吧，如果你曾照看过去一群孩子，你很可能会用以下话语试图平息一场争吵。好了，快说对不起。如果你的建议遭到冷漠、坚决的抵抗，你会想听听这个。香卡，很高兴你来到这里。那么你说的“不道歉”是什么意思？这到底是怎么回事？道歉给我们抛出了一个难题。这个难题，小孩子觉得难，大孩子觉得难，当它是完全理性的时候，这就更难了。所以在刑事司法系统中，例如
severity of their sentence is if they say I'm sorry and time and time again people refuse to apologize So Tyler Oki-Moto who is a researcher at the University of Queensland in Australia, along with his colleagues Michael Wenzel and Kylie Hedrick, they decided to conduct some psychological experiments to understand why people refuse to apologize. Now, parents have been telling their kids for years, look, just say or sorry, you're going to feel better about yourself. Oki-Moto finds that parents have been telling their kids the truth, but they haven't been telling their kids the whole truth. Here he is.
你有这样一种情况：某人被判有罪，正在等待判决，唯一能减轻他们刑罚严重程度的事情就是他们说一句“对不起”，然而一次又一次，人们拒绝道歉。因此，澳大利亚昆士兰大学的研究员泰勒·奥基莫托（Tyler Okimoto）与他的同事迈克尔·文泽尔（Michael Wenzel）和凯莉·海德里克（Kylie Hedrick）决定进行一些心理学实验，以了解人们为什么拒绝道歉。父母多年来一直在告诉他们的孩子，听着，只要说声对不起，你就会对自己的感觉更好一些。奥基莫托发现，父母对孩子说的是实话，但他们并没有把全部事实告诉孩子。他在这里说。
We do find that apologies do make apologizers feel better, but the interesting thing is is that refusals to apologize also makes people feel better, and in fact, in some cases, it makes them feel even better than an apology would have. So what he does is he asks a number of people to remember times when they've harmed someone, and most people, of course, remember trivial things, domestic quarrels and stuff like that, but some people also remember serious harms they've done. They remember crimes such as theft. And Okimoto does two things.
我们确实发现，道歉确实能让道歉者感觉更好，但有趣的是，拒绝道歉也会让人感觉更好，事实上，在某些情况下，它甚至能让人感觉比道歉还要好。所以他做的是，他要求许多人回忆他们曾经伤害过别人的时刻，当然，大多数人回忆的都是些微不足道的小事，比如家庭纠纷之类的事情，但也有一些人回忆起他们犯下的严重伤害。他们回忆起诸如盗窃之类的犯罪。奥基莫托做了两件事。
He asks them, did you actually apologize in real life? And then second, he conducts a laboratory experiment where he asks them to compose an email where they either apologize or they refuse to apologize and what he finds is that both in real life as well as in the laboratory refusing to apologize increases your feelings of status and increases your feelings of integrity. You feel like you have more integrity because you refuse to apologize for something that you know you should apologize for? That's exactly right. The human mind is a wonderful thing, Steve. Okay, so what is the conclusion here? We should never apologize for anything. Well, actually, there are huge interpersonal costs to not apologizing,
他问他们：你在现实生活中真的道歉了吗？其次，他进行了一项实验室实验，要求他们写一封电子邮件，内容要么是道歉，要么是拒绝道歉。他发现，无论是在现实生活中还是在实验室里，拒绝道歉都会增强你的地位感，并增强你的正直感。你觉得自己更有正直感，因为你拒绝为你明知应该道歉的事情道歉？完全正确。人类的大脑真是个奇妙的东西，史蒂夫。好吧，那这里的结论是什么？我们永远不应该为什么事道歉。嗯，事实上，不道歉会产生巨大的痛苦的人际成本，
and not just between individuals, between groups. I mean, think about conflicts that have been stuck for decades because one side can't tell another side. Look, we're really sorry about what we did. The value of Okimoto's research is it starts to get a handle on why people find it so hard to apologize. Here he is again. When you refuse to apologize, it actually makes you feel more empowered. That power and control seems to translate into greater feelings of self-worth. I think I'm getting this because when you apologize, you are putting your fate in someone else's
不仅在个人之间，在群体之间也是如此。我的意思是，想想那些由于一方无法对另一方说“听着，我们对我们所做的事感到非常抱歉”而陷入僵局数十年的冲突。奥基莫托研究的价值在于，它开始让人摸清为什么人们觉得道歉如此困难。他再次说道。当你拒绝道歉时，它实际上会使你感到更有力量。这种权力和控制似乎转化为更高的自我价值感。我想我明白这一点了，因为当你道歉时，你是在把你的命运交到别人手里。
hands. They will accept the apology or not to respond to whoever they do. When you say, I will not apologize, you are still in control. Yeah, and I think this research actually reminds me of the value of something that philosophers have been saying for a very long time, which is being able to apologize is not a sign of weakness. It's actually a sign of strength because if you look at the people who find it difficult to apologize, it's people who feel threatened, who people who feel an apology would somehow make them extremely vulnerable And of course if you're a little kid being asked to apologize you feel vulnerable
他们会接受道歉，或者不接受，并作出他们自己的回应。而当你大声说“我绝不道歉”时，你仍然掌握着控制权。是的，而且我认为这项研究实际上让我想起了哲学家们长期以来一直在说的一个价值，那就是能够道歉并不是软弱的标志。它实际上是力量的标志，因为如果你看看那些觉得道歉很难的人，他们往往是那些感到受到威胁的人，那些觉得道歉会使他们在某种程度上变得极其脆弱的人。当然，如果你是一个被要求道歉的小孩子，你会感到脆弱，
You're you're you're little to begin with and that almost suggested maybe a parent would want to approach that situation a different way If you're actually trying to change people's behavior Love and support might be more effective because if not people end up giving that apology that they don't really mean. They're completely insensitive. Sorry! That was Morning Edition's Stevens' Keep, with a rendition of a totally sincere apology. Coming up, stop what signs with Daniel Pink. We'll tell you how to keep from overeating, overshopping,
你一开始就很弱小，这几乎暗示着也许父母会想用另一种方法来处理这种情况。如果你真的想改变人们的行为，爱和支持可能会更有效，因为如果不这样，人们最终会做出并非出自内心的道歉。他们完全麻木不仁。对不起！这是《早间新闻》的史蒂夫·因斯基普对一次绝对真诚道歉的演绎。接下来，请收听丹尼尔·平克的“停止科学”。我们将告诉你如何在假期中避免暴饮暴食、过度购物以及与亲戚争吵。
and fighting with your relatives this holiday. Back in a moment. Welcome back. We're going to stick with our war and peace and thanksgiving theme in our next segment, which is stop what science. I'm joined as always by Daniel Pink. Hi, Dan. Hey, Shankar.
马上回来。欢迎回来。在我们的下一个环节中，我们将继续保持关于战争、和平与感恩节的主题，也就是“停止科学”。一如既往，和我在一起的是丹尼尔·平克。嗨，丹。嘿，香卡。
Dan and I are going to give one another 60 seconds to describe ideas from social science research. We're going to do things a little differently this time, based on some of your feedback. As we approach the 60 second mark, our producers, Kara and Maggie, will gently bring up the music just like they do with the Oscars. So, Dan, what do you think? This is a kinder, gentler version of Stopwatch Science.
我和丹将给对方60秒的时间来描述社会科学研究中的观点。根据你们的一些反馈，这次我们将采取略有不同的方式。当我们接近60秒大关时，我们的制作人卡拉和玛吉会像奥斯卡颁奖典礼那样，轻柔地把音乐放起来。所以，丹，你怎么看？这是“秒表科学”的一个更温和、更友好的版本。
Kinder, gentler, cluny-esque. Those are three adjectives that describe me very well. They do and they Dan. Alright, so Thanksgiving can be a wonderful time of peace and harmony. In other words, they speak to all of Dan Pink's finest qualities. But sometimes things can go off the rails. Maybe that's because a fight breaks out of the table. Maybe it's simply because you eat too much. On this edition of Stopwatch Science, Dan and I are going to give you tips on how to have a better Thanksgiving. Dan, if you're ready, your first 60 seconds starts now. Well, Shankar, as you say, Thanksgiving for many of us is about resisting temptation.
更温和，更友好，克鲁尼风格。这三个形容词非常准确地描述了我。确实如此，丹。好吧，所以感恩节可以是一个充满和平与和谐的美妙时刻。换句话说，它们体现了丹·平克所有最优秀的品质。但有时事情可能会出轨。也许是因为餐桌上爆发了争吵。也许仅仅是因为你吃得太多了。在本期“秒表科学”中，丹和我将为你提供关于如何过一个更好的感恩节的建议。丹，如果你准备好了，你的前60秒现在开始。嗯，香卡，正如你所说，对我们许多人来说，感恩节就是抵制诱惑。
So how can we do it better? Well, a paper published in the Journal of Consumer Research suggests one secret might be a simple language trick. We should shift from saying, I can't to saying, I don't. Now in one of the experiments undergraduates were trained to resist unhealthy foods by saying to themselves either, I can't eat X or I don't eat X. Later they were offered a choice between chocolate and a healthy granola bar. Of those using the I can't self-talk, fewer than 40% picked a healthy snack. But in the I don't
那么我们该如何做得更好呢？嗯，发表在《消费者研究杂志》上的一篇论文表明，其中的一个秘密可能是一个简单的语言技巧。我们应该把“我不能”的说法转变为“我不”的说法。在其中一项实验中，大学生们通过对自己说“我不能吃X”或“我不吃X”来训练自己抵制不健康的食物。后来，他们在巧克力和健康的格兰诺拉麦片棒之间进行选择。在使用“我不能”自我对话的人中，只有不到40%的人选择了健康零食。但在“我不”
group, nearly two thirds chose the healthier option. Wow. What's going on is what linguists call semantic framing. Semantic framing. Different words give us different views of reality. Cant is disempowering. It implies someone or something else is in control. Don't is empowering. It implies that I'm in charge of what I do, and ultimately, who I am. That's fascinating, Dad, and you were also empowered by the fact that you finished well under 66.
组中，近三分之二的人选择了更健康的选项。哇。这里发生的是语言学家所说的“语义框架”。语义框架。不同的词给我们对现实不同的看法。“不能”会削弱力量。它暗示着别人或别的东西在掌控。而“不”则能赋予力量。它暗示着我在掌控我做的事，并最终掌控我是谁。太迷人了，丹，而且你以远低于60秒的时间完成了这一段，这也让你感到很有力量。
I feel like riding a horse across an open plane right now. I think you forgot to thank your family and your like riding a horse across an open plane right now. I think you forgot to thank your family and your friends for this wonderful movie that's just been made. But I have a question for you, Dan. So I can understand how you can apply this semantic framing when it comes to overeating a Thanksgiving. Can you also apply it to limiting the kind of fights that you have?
我现在感觉就像骑着马在开阔的原野上驰骋一样。我想你刚才忘了感谢你的家人和朋友，感谢他们为你制作了这部刚刚上映的精彩电影。但我有个问题要问你，丹。我能理解当涉及感恩节暴饮暴食时，你如何应用这个语义框架。你也能把它应用到限制你所经历的争吵类型上吗？
Absolutely. I'm thinking in some cases, depending on your family, this might be more useful in that regard. So you can say to yourself, oh, I can't get into cases, depending on your family, this might be more useful in that regard. So you can say to yourself, oh, I can't get into an argument with Uncle Joe, but that might not work nearly as well as saying, you know, I don't get into stupid political fights with people who don't know what they're talking about. I'm going to remember that when I speak with Uncle Joe on Thursday. All right.
当然可以。我想在某些情况下，根据你的家庭情况，这在这方面可能更有用。所以你可以对自己说：“哦，我不能卷入，”根据你的家庭情况，这在这方面可能更有用。所以你可以对自己说：“哦，我不能跟乔叔叔吵架，”但这可能远远不如说：“你知道的，我不会和那些不知道自己在胡说八道的人进行愚蠢的政治争论”那样有效。周四我和乔叔叔说话时我会记住这一点的。好的。
So now on to you, Sean Cart. Your 60 seconds starts right now. Leaf Van Boven at the University of Colorado, George Lohenstein at Carnegie Mellon, and other colleagues recently analyzed a factor that I think plays a role in Thanksgiving table social breakdown stand. It has to do with the concept of hot and cold emotions.
那么现在轮到你了，香卡。你的60秒现在开始。科罗拉多大学的李·范博文、卡耐基梅隆大学的乔治·洛温斯坦以及其他同事最近分析了一个我认为在感恩节餐桌社会崩溃中发挥作用的因素，丹。它与“热情绪”和“冷情绪”的概念有关。
So when I'm not very hungry, for example, I know that I should eat healthy. But when I am hungry, when I'm in the grip of hunger, I forget my resolution. George Lohnstein once told me that the key idea here is not that we have these hot and cold states, but that when we're in a cold state, we are terrible at forecasting how we will behave when we're in the grip of emotions, when we're in the hot state. The researchers recently applied this idea to embarrassing situations. Many of us think we can handle embarrassing situations, but when we're actually confronted
所以当我不饿的时候，例如，我知道我应该吃得健康。但当我饿的时候，当我处于饥饿的控制中时，我就会忘记我的决心。乔治·洛温斯坦曾对我说，这里的核心观点不是我们拥有这些冷热状态，而是当我们在冷状态时，我们极不擅长预测当我们在情绪控制中、处于热状态时我们会如何表现。研究人员最近将这个想法应用到尴尬的情境中。我们许多人认为我们可以处理尴尬的情境，但当我们真正面临
by an embarrassing situation, we fail to act with courage and confidence. I think this plays a role in Thanksgiving table meltdowns. We think we will rise to the occasion to confront that proverbial drunk uncle Joe, but we fail to predict that when he actually starts acting up, we will lapse into silence. Yeah sad but true, what were the actual experiments that they did to demonstrate this? Well, they did a bunch of things. One of the things they did that I thought was very interesting is they asked volunteers to predict whether they would be willing to dance to the 1970 James Brown song Sex Machine. If they agreed to dance in front of others for three four minutes, they would have been given two dollars. Now compared to the number
尴尬的情境时，我们却无法表现出勇气和自信。我认为这在感恩节餐桌的崩溃中起了一定作用。我们以为自己会迎难而上，去对抗那个出了名爱管闲事的醉汉乔叔叔，但我们却没能预测到，当他真的开始胡闹时，我们会陷入沉默。是的，悲伤但真实，他们为了证明这一点到底做了什么实验？嗯，他们做了一堆事情。他们做的一件我认为非常有趣的事情是，他们要求志愿者预测自己是否愿意随着1970年詹姆斯·布朗的歌曲《性感机器》跳舞。如果他们同意在其他人面前跳舞三到四分钟，他们就会得到两美元。现在，与那些预测自己愿意跳舞的志愿者人数相比，实际上只有大约十分之一的人愿意跳舞。所以事实上，当我听到这项研究时，我对自己说，丹和我实际上应该在“停止科学”节目中做这个实验。你愿意在今天的节目结束时随着《性感机器》跳舞吗？我能拿到两块钱吗？我做不到。你确定吗？哦，其实我应该说我不会做那样的事。干得漂亮，丹。干得漂亮。好了，你的下一个60秒现在开始。好的。这里有个好消息，用火鸡、肉汁和甜山药塞满你的嘴可能有个好处。
of volunteers who predicted that they would be willing to dance, about one in ten were actually willing to dance. So in fact, when I heard about the study, I told myself, Dan and I should actually run this experiment during stop-what science. Would you be willing to dance to sex machine at the end of the second today? Do I get two bucks? I can't do that. Are you sure? Oh, actually I should say I don't do something like that. Well played down. Well played. All right Your next 60 seconds starts right now. All right. Here's some good news stuffing your face with turkey gravy and candy dams Might have an upside.
在预测自己愿意跳舞的志愿者中，大约十分之一的人实际上愿意跳舞。所以事实上，当我听说这项研究时，我对自己说，丹和我实际上应该在“暂停科学”期间做这个实验。你愿意在今天第二节结束时随着《性机器》跳舞吗？我能拿到两块钱吗？我做不到。你确定吗？哦，其实我应该说我不会做那样的事。干得好，丹。干得漂亮。好吧，你的下一个60秒从现在开始。好吧。这里有个好消息，吃饱火鸡肉汁和糖果大坝可能会有积极的一面。
A rule in Hamanchu, Mishra, there a husband and wife team at the University of Utah have found that on Thanksgiving, what's bad for your waistline might actually be good for your wallet. A few years ago, they interrupted 170 people on Thanksgiving evening, and they asked those people how willing they'd be to buy deeply discounted items. The researchers found that those who need a traditional holiday meal were significantly less likely to be seduced by the bargains. What's going on here?
犹他州大学的夫妻档雷曼奇·米什拉发现，在感恩节，对你的腰围不好的事情实际上可能对你的钱包有好处。几年前，他们在感恩节当晚打断了170个人，询问这些人购买深度折扣商品的意愿如何。研究人员发现，那些享用了传统节日大餐的人明显不那么容易被大促销所诱惑。这里发生了什么？
In a word, serotonin. That's a brain chemical that regulates mood. When serotonin goes up, which it does when we eat triptophan-heavy foods like turkey and rich carbohydrates like mashed potatoes, our impulsiveness goes down. In other words, if you want to save money on Black Friday, pick out on Thanksgiving Thursday. I love it, then. I have to say that I have an alternate theory, though, which is that the people who have eaten so much at Thanksgiving, they might just be in a food coma.
简而言之，就是血清素。这是一种调节情绪的大脑化学物质。当血清素上升时——当我们吃富含色氨酸的食物（如火鸡）和丰富的碳水化合物（如土豆泥）时就会这样——我们的冲动就会下降。换句话说，如果你想在黑色星期五省钱，就在感恩节星期四暴饮暴食吧。我喜欢，丹。不过我必须说，我有一个替代理论，那就是在感恩节吃得太多的人可能只是陷入了食物昏迷中。
They just physically not able to get to the telephone to speak to telemarketers. So it's an interesting theory, it's a testable theory. My hunch is that the research would validate that being in a food coma reduces your impulsiveism. So on that, let's go to your second and final study, Shankar, your 60 seconds starts right now. All right, we've known for a very long time
他们身体上根本无法走到电话机旁去跟电话推销员说话。所以这是一个有趣的理论，这是一个可检验的理论。我的直觉是，研究将证实陷入食物昏迷会减少你的冲动。那么在这个基础上，我们来看你的第二个也是最后一个研究，香卡，你的60秒现在开始。好的，我们很早就知道了
that children are easily distracted by bright and shiny objects. Turns out, adults are too, and this can be a very useful idea to apply a Thanksgiving. Martin Reiman at the University of Arizona, and Antoine Bessara and Deborah McKinnis at the University of Southern California, they ran an experiment.
小孩子很容易被明亮闪闪发光的物体分散注意力。事实证明，成年人也是如此，这可以成为感恩节派对上一个非常实用的想法。亚利桑那大学的马丁·雷曼，以及南加州大学的安托万·贝萨拉和黛博拉·麦金尼斯，他们进行了一项实验。
They set up a food stand and offered people chicken nuggets, beef tacos, and bacon avocado sandwiches. They told the volunteers that if they chose a half serving instead of a full serving, they would get a lottery ticket, a chance to win either a hundred dollar Amazon gift card or 10,000 frequent flyer miles. And they measured how likely people would have chosen the full serving versus the half serving. They found that about two thirds of the volunteers chose the full serving without the lottery incentive but with the lottery tickets that number dropped by more than half. If people thought they could win a prize, they ate less. In other words, if you want to incentivize people to eat in moderation or behave nicely at Thanksgiving,
他们设置了一个食品摊，向人们提供鸡块、牛肉塔可和培根牛油果三明治。他们告诉志愿者，如果他们选择半份而不是全份，他们就会得到一张彩票，有机会赢得一百美元的亚马逊礼品卡或一万点常旅客里程。他们测量了人们选择全份与半份的可能性。他们发现，大约三分之二的志愿者在没有彩票激励的情况下选择了全份，但在有了彩票后，这个数字下降了一半以上。如果人们认为自己能赢得奖品，他们就会吃得更少。换句话说，如果你想激励人们在感恩节适度饮食或表现得体，
the answer is simple, hand out lottery tickets. Well, that's great. I really think you've uncovered the true meaning of Thanksgiving, which is handing out cash prizes for Dumlock. That's what this country is all about. That's exactly right. What's me in the holiday spirit? There you go.
答案很简单，分发彩票。好吧，太棒了。我真的认为你发现了感恩节的真正含义，那就是为走运分发现金奖品。这个国家就是这个样子的。完全正确。这让我有了节日的气氛。就是这样。
That was Dan Pink, our Senior Stop-Wat Science correspondent. Dan, thank you for playing Stop-Wat Science today. It's always a blast. You can follow us on Twitter and Facebook. For more Hidden Brain, you can also tune into a local public radio station. The Hidden Brain podcast is produced by Karam Agar-Kalasin and Maggie Pennman. I'm Shankar Vedantam. I wish you a very happy Thanksgiving. This is NPR. Very happy Thanksgiving.
那是我们的高级“停止科学”记者丹·平克。丹，谢谢你今天参加“停止科学”。这总是非常开心。你可以在推特和Facebook上关注我们。想要了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，你也可以收听当地的公共广播电台。《隐藏的大脑》播客由卡拉·阿加尔-卡拉辛和玛吉·彭曼制作。我是香卡·维达塔姆。祝你感恩节快乐。这里是美国国家公共电台。非常快乐的感恩节。
This is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这里是美国国家公共电台。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。